foreign
blockades
are hurting canadians
whether they're in ottawa windsor coots
or emerson
they're endangering jobs
they're threats to our economy and to
public safety
the blockades are hurting small
businesses and neighborhoods
at the border they're impacting trade
supply chains and manufacturing
the people these blockades are hurting
our everyday families
auto assembly workers farmers
truckers
and blue-collar canadians
this morning i spoke with david cassidy
of unifor
who told me how badly
this is hurting workers in southern
ontario
we both agreed that blockades are
unacceptable
and that they have to end
for the good of all canadians
today
foreign
yesterday with mayor drew dilkins of
windsor to offer
the full and continued support of the
federal government
minister al capra as well as ministers
blair mendicino and leblanc
are also in regular contact with their
counterparts
ontario's announcement this morning is
responsible and necessary
we will continue working alongside all
partners to get the situation under
control
this morning i had a direct call with
president biden to talk about our shared
challenges at the border
i updated him on the situation
particularly in windsor
we discussed the american and indeed
global influences on the protest
we talked about the u.s based flooding
of the 911 phone lines in ottawa the
presence of u.s citizens in the
blockades
and the impact of foreign money to fund
this illegal activity
president biden and i both agree that
for the security of people and the
economy
these blockades cannot continue
so make no mistake
the border cannot and will not remain
closed
i want to remind everyone
that politicians don't direct police in
a democratic society but i can assure
you that the rcmp is working with
provincial and local police departments
to enforce the law
everything is on the table
because this unlawful activity has to
end
and it will end
of course
i can't say too much more now as to
exactly when or how this ends because
unfortunately we are concerned about
violence so we're taking every
precaution to keep people safe but the
absolute
safest way for this to end
is for everyone to return to your
communities
now
if you're still participating in illegal
blockades
you're hurting your neighbors
so it's time to go home
especially
if you have kids with you
don't need
should not be
canada's
laws regulations and practices that
ensure funds cannot be used for criminal
act or illegal activity and these
blockades
are illegal
canadian banks are monitoring financial
activity very closely and taking action
as necessary
i want to make something very clear
the illegal blockades seeking to take
our neighborhoods and our economy
hostage
and the collective covered fatigue we
are facing
are two very separate things
if you joined the protests because
you're tired of covid
you now need to understand
that you're breaking laws
the consequences are becoming more and
more severe
you don't end up losing your license
end up with a criminal record which will
impact your job
your livelihood
even your ability to travel
internationally including to the u.s
we've heard your frustration with kovid
with the measures that are there to keep
people safe
we've heard you
it's time to go home now
and to the people who are tired of this
pandemic
that is all canadians
i want you
to be able to get back to the things
that you love
i hear you
all of you
parliamentarians hear it in their
communities we all hear it from friends
and family
from people like laurie from here in
ontario who wrote to me to say she
disagrees with the bad behavior of the
blockaders
but she's also tired of the restrictions
or helen from toronto who's worried
about what the restrictions are doing to
children's mental health
i understand
we don't want these measures to last
longer than they should
and we never did
but the truth is
because of
all of our efforts
we saved more lives in canada
than in many other countries
we helped people like samuel from
courtney bc who also wrote to tell me
that as a health care worker our
measures
are keeping him safe
is
foreign
we consider and reconsider what's
possible and what's best
to protect canadians
i have multiple meetings every week to
talk about what the next step are
this morning for example i spoke with dr
tam and minister duklow among others
about the plan to adjust travel measures
under federal jurisdiction
as canadians
it's important to continue being there
for one another
we're fighting a virus
we're not fighting each other
people are making sacrifices and have
been for the past two years
it's never the time
to hurt our economy and fellow canadians
with illegal blockades but especially
not now
after all we've sacrificed together
after all we've done
to get back to the things we love
and reopen our lives
i'd also like
during the summit with president biden
and allies we discussed the importance
of finding a peaceful solution that
remains our focus
we're all concerned
that russia is continuing to build up
its truth presence
and looking actively for excuses to act
instead
russia must de-escalate
the west is standing firm together
coordinated and ready to impose severe
costs including sanctions
if russia
invades ukraine once again
we're also strengthening our support and
presence through nato
and we will continue
to support ukraine democracy
sovereignty and independence and
more than anything else
continue to support
the people of ukraine
this is an evolving situation but the
bottom line is this
we're not seeking confrontation with
russia
but we're resolved
to stand firm with the ukrainian
people's right
to determine their own future
thank you prime minister merci communist
we will now begin with 20 minutes of
questions starting with 10 minutes
from the room followed by 10 minutes by
the phone
oh i mean
we will come outside like this
10 minutes
over the television
first question
hello prime minister mike blanchfield
canadian press it's been two weeks and
only now is the ontario government
taking concrete steps until now your
government
has simply said you'll continue to
provide resources when asked so why has
it taken
two weeks 15 days
for any government anywhere to do
something directly to address this
crisis now
from the very beginning we have been
supporting
the ottawa police force and the province
of ontario with any resources they need
to keep public order to
ensure that they're able to move forward
on
ending these blockades i think
citizens of ottawa indeed all canadians
are impatient for them
to be done
for people to go home
the message has been clear people have
been heard
in this country jurisdictions work
together
to ensure the right outcomes for
citizens and every step of the way the
federal government has been there with
resources with support
with guidance
and
engagement
that is getting us through this one step
at a time
is
illegal
this conflict
i know you don't like to talk about your
father's legacy but he faced some
similar decisions in 1970 about the use
of the canadian forces in a civilian law
enforcement capacity you said a moment
ago everything's on the table could you
explain uh to what extent military is
being considered and also
how much did your father's experience
back then color your own reaction to
this and the decision that you may still
have to make
i think
the
as i've said many times my values are
deeply informed by the way i've brought
been brought up not just by my father
but by my experiences as a canadian i
think that's what every politician
brings to bear the core values that they
stand for but every situation is
different what we're seeing right now is
people who are
frustrated deeply
by this unprecedented global pandemic
that has been hitting canadians so hard
over these past two years
leaving people
tired
frustrated angry
wanting it to be done
unfortunately we know
this pandemic doesn't end because we
cross our arms and decide that it's over
this pandemic will end
by following science
by supporting each other by being there
for each other as canadians have done
throughout these past two years
as a government we made a promise
to have people's backs every step of the
way
that means
doing the things that keep people safe
and supported and get our economy to
come roaring back
as quickly as possible for everyone
and that's why these blockades
that are not helping this pandemic end
any sooner that are hurting our supply
chains hurting families across the
country
endangering our recovery both from the
health crisis and
from the economic crisis
are so wrong
and that's why we are going to continue
to use the tools
that we have
as
a society
to ensure that these blockades end and
that starts with local police forces
having the support
of
orders of government of national police
resources
that's how we are getting through this
process
foreign
foreign
you're talking today about support and
resources there's an outstanding request
from the ottawa police for 1800 officers
that hasn't been filled you're talking
about talking with mayors and premiers
is that supposed to provide comfort to
businesses in centertown that have been
closed for a week to auto workers who
are being laid off because the
ambassador bridge is closed
we have provided hundreds of police
officers
two jurisdictions that needed them
including ottawa
the request for 1600 officers was
carefully examined by
what the opp and experts within the rcmp
leadership to look at what exactly the
plan is what is exactly needed and what
is needed is being provided to be able
to move through this in a peaceful
responsible way but again
the best way to resolve this the best
way to stop hurting
canadian citizens
hard-working canadians across this
country
is for the people in these protests
to understand that they have been heard
but it's time to go home it's time to
bring your kids home from this protest
it is now
an illegal protest
and the consequences on them and on
their families
will be significant if they choose to
continue with this illegal activity
[Music]
category
is
i've been very very clear
that using
uh military
uh forces against civilian populations
in canada or in any other democracy
is something to avoid having to do at
all costs
that's why
the solution right now is focused on
police forces
enforcing the laws
that exist
protecting public order in the way that
they are trained to do
in a
predictable
progressive
approach that doesn't skip any steps
that works to conclude this situation
peacefully
that's why
right now it has become a lot more
difficult and a lot more impactful and
quite frankly expensive
for people who are in those protests
because they're tired of covid
to continue to be part of these illegal
protests the consequences on their lives
for choosing to continue
to endanger the lives and livelihoods of
other canadians
to continue to violate our laws
are going to be more and more extensive
and therefore
we are very hopeful that people will
choose to leave these protests
peacefully now that they've been heard
there are further steps for law
enforcement to take as
that happens or not but we are a long
way
from ever having to call in the military
although of course
we have to be
ready for any eventuality
but
it is not something we are seriously
contemplating at this time
uh prime minister i'm wondering if you
have any regrets about the approach that
you've taken to the protesters at any
time especially your comments when they
first arrived do you think that actually
helped or do you think it sort of
angered them and they felt misunderstood
and caused protesters to really dig in
so to speak i think
there was a lot of canadians scratching
their heads at the fact that
[Music]
protesters who
purported to speak for truckers
actually didn't represent the 90
of truckers who are vaccinated
i think where
they certainly struck a chord with a lot
of canadians is that people are tired of
covid they're tired of the restrictions
but at the same time as a government
we made a promise to canadians to have
their backs every step of the way for as
long as it takes and part of having
people's backs
is making sure that the public health
measures that we bring in
the supports for canadians
the supports for provinces that bring in
restrictions
these are the things that get us through
this pandemic these are the things that
save lives and we are going to continue
to follow the science and do what is
necessary to keep canadians safe every
step of the way because quite frankly
canadians stepped up
90 of canadians got vaccinated
people have been there for each other
they're united in wanting to be there
for each other they're also united and
being sick and tired of this pandemic
those two things can be true and are
true
and our responsibility as
orders of government
is to continue to be there for them
every step of the way
is
for questions over the phone for ten
minutes
one question one follow-up
for questions over the phone please
press
star one on the devices keypad
the first question is from olivia
stefanovic from cbc news please go ahead
your line is open hi prime minister
trudeau
provinces are listing vaccine passports
and your government as we understand it
is moving to list the pcr testing around
travel are you concerned that the
protesters will claim victory for these
changes and this will embolden them
further
i think different provinces are
taking decisions that they feel are
appropriate to them on vaccine mandates
and restrictions they have in their
jurisdictions
as you know the federal government has
responsibility over the borders
over
international travel
and over
the federal public service
as i said we had
extensive meetings today on the next
steps that we look forward to taking and
we'll be making announcements regarding
our border posture next week
are you concerned though that any
announcements you do make could could
reach these protesters claiming victory
and then holding them further
um
i think it's extremely important to
emphasize that all the decisions we take
will be based in science and indeed um
we'll be focused on canadians getting
their lives back to normal
i can emphasize that many of the
measures that we've been talking about
for a long time for example the measures
that canadian the canadian government
brought in
on
needing to be vaccinated to get on a
plane or a train
or needing to be vaccinated to work in
the federal public service are not among
the things that we are considering
changing we're continuing to look at the
posture to ensure
that people are able
to
get back to the things they love as this
omicron wave begins to recede
thank you
the next question
is walsh from the globe and bell please
go ahead your line is open
good afternoon thanks for taking our
questions you spoke briefly at the
beginning about foreign funding
marika i think we lost you
[Music]
[Music]
so the next question will be from the
mick charles of the toronto star please
go ahead your mind is open
[Music]
the promises taking now finally are
reasonable and necessary
but i want to go back to the question of
why it's taken so long at 6 15 days was
it the border blockages in other words
should the protesters have to work
sorry you were cutting in and out a
little bit uh
tonda can you repeat the end of your
question
did it take so long
was this thing only
coordinated in all of your responses
because of the border blockages did that
plastic work
obviously uh the
concern that we're facing on the borders
is significant we're seeing
six different auto plants have to shut
down over the past days because
of
lack of parts flowing across the
ambassador bridge in windsor we're
seeing supply chains disrupted uh out
west because the kutz border chain
border crossing uh and in ontario
because of the the windsor crossing
these are things that we are absolutely
taking extremely seriously but we have
been taking the situation seriously from
uh from the very beginning and working
with
partners municipal and federal uh to put
an end to these
peacefully and responsibly that is the
job of police police officers and police
forces
the responsibility of politicians is to
ensure
that the police forces have the tools
and the resources they need that's what
we've been doing but we do not direct
the local police of jurisdiction uh even
when they're in proximity to an
international border crossing we all
work together and quite frankly
regardless of the uh
the the the conversations being going on
between jurisdictions i can assure you
that on the ground uh the actual
cohesion and alignment with all
different police forces federal
provincial and municipal has been
exemplary
follow-up
what did president biden tell you about
the u.s influence
or participation in the canadian protest
and how will cut off
any foreign funding
obviously president biden expressed his
concern for the well-being of canadians
and indeed
for the jobs uh and economic ties that
flow back and forth across our border
every single day um
he expressed uh concern not just uh for
the impacts right now but at the
indication that there is international
support from the united states and from
elsewhere around the world for these
protests we've seen
that the
attack for example on the ottawa 9-1-1
system
came from the united states we see that
almost half of the funding
through certain portals that is flowing
to
the
barricaders here in canada
is coming from the united states we see
a mobilization of
some of the more
challenging political elements
in canada and in the united states
around support for these blockades that
are hurting citizens
we are going to continue to work
together as we have been
on resolving this situation but also on
strengthening our institutions and our
democratic principles
operator can we go back to marica for a
question
yes thank you
miss walsh that you could press star one
please on the devices keypad
next question me collage the globe and
mail
please go ahead
good afternoon prime minister can you
please provide us with some more details
about the percentage of the funds that
the
federal government believes is coming
from the us and what percentage of the
people in the crowds are actually
americans
those aren't uh details that i have
right in front of me i've heard that on
certain platforms the number of
u.s donations are approaching 50
but we can make sure that we uh
we ensure that uh that the that
information is shared with you on that
uh in terms of the presence of americans
in our protests i can assure you that
our police services are monitoring
carefully and
watching and coordinating with partner
agencies around the world
follow up
thank you and the u.s has said that it's
offered support to the federal
government has the federal government
accepted that support and what
specifically is it
i don't want to get into operational
details but i can assure you that the
conversations directly
between governor whitmer of
michigan and our officials and indeed
with the white house have ensured us of
resources and support if necessary and
the folks on the ground are working out
what is necessary and what could be used
as we move forward
next question
thank you mayor
next question is from justin lane
freelance please go ahead the light is
open
good afternoon prime minister you've
made it clear that a military option is
the last last last resort um you're
still pleading with them to go home
these protesters have made it clear
they're not leaving they're not
listening to you
they don't really have much interest in
what you have to say so what comes next
what is the next part of the federal
solution here given how overwhelmed the
city of ottawa is
first of all justin i i don't accept uh
the contention that the city of ottawa
has
exhausted its tools and its resources
the ottawa police force has been
given resources from both the opp
and the and the rcmp
there is
concerted efforts around planning and
approaches that will
move forward in a proportional way
but i think it is very clear that the
time for these protests to end
has come
people who are there because they're
tired
of covert restrictions we understand
that everyone is tired of covet
restrictions um
but
we need to make sure that our laws are
followed in this country and our laws
will be enforced that's the role of the
ottawa police force that's the role of
police of jurisdictions across this
country
and they will as the premier indicated
today
be enforcing
stronger and stronger measures
that will make it more and more
difficult for the protesters to in good
conscience choose to stay part of
illegal protests
follow-up and this will be the last
question
the prime minister at the top you said
that a more aggressive enforcement
action is right now off the table
because of the risk of violence people
hear that and they get really worried
there's concerns that weapons may be
present in the occupied area uh there's
concern about what those districts will
do if police try and make a rest do you
have any visibility on that do you have
uh any indication of exactly what
elements are in that crowd and what
potential for violence there actually is
i can assure you that i have been
briefed regularly by both our
intelligence agencies and
police agencies on the risk levels to
civilians including
protesters and vulnerable people within
the protest there are people who are
there with their kids
in these protests
and their well-being is of course top of
mind
for the police services as it is the
well-being of uh citizens in and around
the protests as well who just are trying
to go through their daily lives
there is always a concern around
escalation but the police have a
robust framework within which they go
step by step on making it more and more
difficult for the protests to continue
more and more expensive for people to
choose to stay in the protest both in
ways financial but also an impact of
their lives and livelihood
it is time for these protesters to go
home it is time to recognize that this
protest this blockade is illegal
and
those consequences on
people choosing to remain
will be
increasingly challenging and the police
have the tools to move forward in a
step-by-step approach that will
bring back order to the city of ottawa
and indeed to our border crossings
now see me paying our confidence